the other day suddenly out of the blue
while we were talking about something
completely different
my partner Dorothy my friend and
companion burr start as follows on the
other hand she said on the other hand
how proud your mother would have been
what a pity she isn't still alive and
your father - how proud they would have
been of you even prouder than of my son
the doctor I said even proud of an of my
son the professor even prouder if my
mother was still alive I said she would
be 99 and a half she would probably have
senile dementia she would not know what
was going on around her but of course I
missed the point
Dorothy was right my mother would have
been bursting with pride my son the
Nobel Prize winner and for whom anyway
do we do the things that lead to Nobel
Prizes if not for our mothers
mommy mommy
mommy mommy I won a prize
that's wonderful my dear now eat your
carrots before they get cold why must
our mothers be 99 and long in the grave
before we can come running home with the
prize that will make up for all the
trouble we have been to them too Alfred
Nobel 107 years in the grave and with
the foundation that's faithfully
administers his will and that has
created this magnificent evening for us
my heartfelt gratitude to my parents our
sorry I am that you cannot be here thank
you